the big conflict of black panther two
will be
one that introduces t'challa to this
neighbor
storm monroe i actually think each phase
four title
could introduce a different mutant in
the mcu that'd be really fun and black
panther too it could be storm
in the comments leave your pee stories
like subscribe and pee
oh my god the only way quarantined will
end is if you reveal your piss stories
to us
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back this is rogue
theory the podcast that brings you the
wildest nerdy hot takes on topics that
you can't stop arguing about that's
right the beatles were all about peace
and love
but here at new rock stars we're all
about fighting
and ending personal relationships over
things you disagree on the stuff that
matters most
comic book movies sci-fi sagas physical
comic books themselves
dogs you may not like the way they look
at you fight over it's time to call out
your girlfriend
call out your boyfriend give your wife
divorce papers this is rogue theory
today to pitch with me their best rogue
theories are
new rockstar's own resident king
eric voss thank you for having me on and
for getting my title right this time
yes thank you daddy and writer and
comedian jessica clemens
hi uh no photos but maybe i can
um
[Music]
and finally our relationship sexpert and
off-screen producer dr zach huddleston
um that that title will make more sense
in a few minutes
no no we're not this is it we're going
to be a very short one this week
all right after three grueling mcu
phases in which
pretty much no one ever no one gets it
on noah moore
uh love will take center stage in phase
four
with thor love and thunder and juan
division
but uh we've also seen some evidence
that there might be some secret squeezes
uh
going down with big implications on
upcoming plot points in the mcu
so my darlings pitch me what surprise
power couple
will have the biggest implications on
marvel's future eric
let's hear from you bachelor number one
okay
um well i uh like long
nights sitting inside playing board
games
and nothing else okay uh i would like to
marry you
okay done thanks for playing everybody
bye-bye
i come out strong i come out strong um
okay here's my theory when it comes to
sex scandals i would say no goss is
hotter than
royal ones because think about it that
stuff only really matters when there's
like lineages and
stuff to think about and the people
sleeping around are in positions of
political power so i believe king
t'challa of wakanda the black panther is
having an affair
and actually if you look at the evidence
hidden in the mcu it's with the mutant
storm aurora monroe oh my god
whoa so am i just gonna say there's
evidence and leave it at that no
i got receipts hear me out hear me out
here
so uh in black panther uh there was that
moment where t'challa okoye nakia
get into that korean nightclub and they
do so by posing as wealthy tourists from
which country
kenya and i would assume that if they
were going to do that they would have to
have some kind of forged passports or
paperwork with kenyan identification on
it meaning they would need to have some
kind of contacts
in that country high ranking in the
government ones they can
trust with discretion also in the
captain marvel post-credits scene when
they were looking at those global death
counts that were um you know getting
immediately counted yet somehow we
probably won't have election uh results
uh the same
day in this country uh there was uh
those numbers
presented uh on different countries
around the world but the camera lingered
specifically on one country what country
kenya kenya why am i doing this stupid
socratic [ __ ] they said there were
27 million
already reported missing it's almost as
if marvel really wants us to remember
that kenya
is a country in the world but
specifically that it's
super near wakanda and eastern africa
but you know why is kenya important it's
a
it's of course the home to aurora monroe
storm and i'm not just making this up
uh black panther and storm have a long
relationship in the marvel comics they
well they were kind of on again off
again for a bit but they get married
they're they are marvel's power couple
for uh for an extended period of time
uh and i believe that the big conflict
of black panther ii
will be one that introduces t'challa to
this neighbor storm rory monroe i
actually think
each phase four title could introduce a
different mutant in the mcu that'd be
really fun
and black panther too it could be storm
uh and i think their romance is going to
create a controversy within wakanda
some might say he really should have
been betrothed
to nakia but she's on her own journey
she didn't show up an infinity war end
game
she's not interested in any of that but
uh storm
based off her comic's history is but
she's non-wakandan i think there's gonna
be some
parts of the country of wakanda who
think that's going to weaken t'challa's
position but
it's going to come at the worst possible
time because i believe that they're
going to be facing a threat
from another rival kingdom atlantis led
by
neymar and you can cue your okoye
endgame line here that we show in pretty
much every video
it's an earthquake under the ocean we
handle it
by not handling it so i think that's
going to be the big award that's going
on
and uh we actually had one of our
friends on discord uh gandalf dr adam
beshear who pitched this really cool
idea that i like of
neymar flooding wakanda yeah i love that
as a way to like even the playing field
but whether it's this or something else
i think it's going to be on storm to use
her powers of manipulating the weather
to end up freeing and saving this uh
endangered nation
that uh many of whom didn't really
appreciate her or like her
in order to save them and win their
trust and uh to join the ranks of the
other
world heroes of the avengers in future
marvel properties
i love it yes a classic romance so on
again off again will they won't day
stormy stormy romances i love a stormy
romance uh i like a calm romance as well
every now and then i don't mind a calm
romance
eric i'm going to shoot you through the
heart with two cupid's arrows for that
you're getting two
cupid's arrows oh topped tommy oh
tommy yes those ear arrows on my end
uh became two things that i love more
than most
the florida gators go gators
uh gator nations everywhere i can't they
won't fit over my headphones they won't
it won't fit on my head anyway i think
that's okay because college eric had a
much smaller cranium
uh but a broken pair of sunglasses from
my friends ricky and katie's wedding
that uh that i carry with me at all
times
that's so good puns are out
okay i like that i like that a lot nice
all right jessica what do you got for me
our bachelorette number two jessica what
do we have
well i'm 26 years old um i come from
i come from bend oregon and
my dad's a teacher and my mom's um a
therapist so i have a lot of money
no okay so so i have a lot of money if
you're interested
okay side to that
yes um i agree i agree with my my friend
my colleague my partner
uh my my pillow
pillow pet uh eric boss we love
our romance with the royals yes we
we love royal romance we love a little
like dirty secret we love a little thing
that like
none of us saw really coming you know
we're like oh what
we kind of also love a little triangle
love so that's why i think
what we need to all acknowledge is that
the romantic relationship that's gonna
hit the mcu
is gamora and adam warlock because and
yes because what we got in um guardians
of the galaxy volume 2 and the stinger
we got obviously the um aisha building
something that was in a golden cocoon
that is we know is warlock and we're
like
if we know the comics has a thing with
gamora
um and we love bringing them comics up
so we have we love stir in that comic
pot
and so we have we have warlock right
coming back
and being sentenced to kill the
guardians basically
and what i think will happen is that
this is also for your information
garden's a galaxy three
this isn't just some ram this is an
avengers starring only guardians this is
going on
got it just to clarify but i think what
will happen
is that aisha will obviously tell
warlock that thanos
completely destroyed half the population
in the galaxy we all came back but he
had to give up his one daughter gamora
so obviously the guardians are no match
to warlock while they got rid of gamora
so he's like okay
no pressure i'm gonna go over there i'm
just gonna blow up that ship boom boom
boom bam
and so he flies through the galaxy finds
them and figures out that gamora is
still alive
and then he's like going hand-in-hand
combat with her maybe there's a little
bit of flirting in that because we're
dealing with the new gamora we're not
dealing with the old gamora that has
ties to her team
and ties to quill we have a new gamer
that has a blank slate
that has no ties to anyone truly she's
just going through the world
and so i think we're going to see that
and quill will notice it and get a
little jealous
but i will spoil my own spoiler and say
at the end
i do think that uh gamora
and warlock will end up together and
quill will go on being like this is a
new
oh god sorry cough this is a new gamora
you got you got emotional you got
emotional about quill's speech
my baby boy my son that house
that has shown so much growth through
this entire franchise
let's be real losing his dad and his mom
yeah so
i think he'll go through and he'll be
like she's a new person this is a new
gamora this isn't the gamora i know
which is okay this is her own right this
is his own person
we also have warlock joining the team of
guardians later in the comic book series
which i think
could still happen um there is a side to
this very where
which i would love to see because we all
know warlock has the capability to
literally resurrect people without even
the soul stone
so it would be cool to see him resurrect
the old gomorrah
and maybe use her as leverage to lure
the at the guardians to come fight him
he'll be like i have
the gamora you want this is his face
[Music]
[Laughter]
um so i think that that relationship
will come to play
i think we'll i think this would
probably be like the end for the
guardians franchise
um except for when they show up in the
avengers movies but it would be a nice
ending
to see even like gamora with a new love
because it's always like even in the
comics
she thought of quill as just like a
child and he loved her
so i think that still is playing they're
not together
they're just like hey we can feel we
want a shipment but we might not get it
but we will get it
ah great i like that uh well let me tell
you what
i was gonna give you three arrows to the
heart but i'm only giving you two
because you missed the opportunity to
name them gamorlock
as their ship name and i was right there
for you
so i'm going to shoot it breaks my heart
to do this i'm going to shoot two
cupid's arrows into you and and and
we'll ship gamorlock together you know
what it's okay because they came to me
as hand sanitizer oh nice it's great
thank you yeah sure um this
v bic bic velocity point
one yeah um that i still got my job
a long time ago name name brand pens and
by the way if you're not stealing pens
from your job you're not working smart
okay you're not working smart you should
be stealing nobody should ever pay for a
pen
never never pay 100 15 a week minimum
all right or a ream of paper uh an
industrial copier
staples that you don't need those old
computers that are in the corner that
nobody will claim and no one will pay to
recycle
take them home and smash them make a
fort out of them
make a rumble what are you doing what
are you doing what are you
doing i work in a junkyard uh all right
bachelor number three uh i just got off
of a crazy relationship where i heard
two theories
if you had to tell me one theory about a
relationship what would it be
first off um i like long walks on the
beach i never
rinse dishes before i put them in the
dishwasher oh yeah and
i i go through bouts of brutal gas yeah
all i'm hearing is the one in the middle
and that is no pre-rinse and baby i'm on
the no pre-ridge train as well let's go
it's a waste of time okay um
i really liked both uh eric and
jessica's theories i want to see those
play out but my theory my couple
is is a little bit more messed up this
is not a happy romance
okay maybe there's some like elements of
kink
it's a little dark it's maybe a little
bit sick okay
and so mine's gonna take place uh in
captain marvel 2.
okay carol has not had a love interest
yet okay in the movies uh also carol
is insanely powerful at this point right
as an end of end game
she can fly through a spaceship kick
anybody's ass
um crazy super powerful and so this
relationship
is gonna deal with that a little bit she
is going to be in a relationship with
rogue the namesake
of this show
yes okay so in the comics right and this
goes all the way back to the 70s like
the first time we ever met
rogue she was kind of in a in a fight
with
um then miss marvel carol danvers
and of course she used her rogue power
she touched her sucked out
all of her good you know super juice
basically oh yeah
absorbed all of her powers and
absorbed some of her memories basically
gave carol amnesia
right and like absorbed all of the
captain marvel memories
so then that that led to this kind of
played out over the years they kind of
picked it back up in the 90s and it's
it's become kind of a permanent part of
of rogue's character right because like
the the rogue we saw in the early 2000s
those x-men movies right who
has the kind of touch you steal your
life force
abilities but you can't fly she's not
super strong
right whereas in the comics that's been
a big part of her character ever since
she absorbed those qualities from marvel
i think there's going to be a
relationship
right this kind of classic toxic
relationship where the road we're going
to meet
very different than the anna paquin
version we saw in the 2000s right
she's uh maybe a villain right maybe
she's out to manipulate
uh do something like that with carol
sucks up
a lot of her captain marvel juice right
thus becoming super powerful herself
maybe this this could be a platonic
relationship i'm in a pitch that it's
romantic why not that adds
an interesting element of like power
control
abuse whatever right you can kind of put
all those into the soup
um and so that that does a couple of
things
great now we have this great antagonist
for captain marvel 2. we get to like
eric mentioned we get to introduce
another mutant
right one at a time slowly build out
that roster
just like we did with avengers in the
mcu um and
right like maybe again the the in the
canon of the comics
right rogue kind of you know weakens you
a little bit and
gain some juice for herself but if she
touches you long enough she like
permanently
takes some of your powers and i don't
know some kind of middle ground there
but if if she absorbs a lot of this
power from captain marvel
that both like takes captain marvel down
a couple notches which i think
could be nice right like that way we get
to see her be an underdog
figure again like we saw in her first
movie and she's not this crazy super
powerful end game version of herself
right so now she has to kind of fight
her way back out baby
also a part of the comics right rogue
when she absorbs all these memories
she kind of like that's kind of the
turning point for her when she becomes a
good guy because she kind of
she feels a lot of guilt from what she
did to captain marvel and like
absorbing her memories she kind of
understands her and empathizes with her
more
so i think like this kind of sets up
right like both we get evil rogue that's
a new version of her that eventually
turns good
takes kept marvel down a couple notches
makes her fight her way up and we get
this weird kind of funky
um quasi-toxic relationship between the
two of them
zach you know you know me pretty well
you know i love a good toxic
relationship you know
if it ain't toxic if it ain't toxic i
ain't talking
because people
people who support each other not for me
what i like is systematically trying to
destroy each other from the inside
via a relationship and trust me i'm damn
good at it
i'm really good at it guys uh you struck
me there and i'm gonna strike you right
back with
two uh cupid's arrows through your heart
as well
ooh okay well um those have become the
fitting of my theory
uh this version of anna pacquiao and
rogue in this version of more comics
accurate
you know keep those arrows coming buddy
because there's a giant bucket of rogue
figurines
oh boy i uh i just watched uh the
original x-men with my
nephews and man i forgot how crazy that
first x-men movie was that was
that's a while it's a wild movie there's
a lot of light
i love it yeah it's all about it it is i
do like it though you're right
i i feel the same way that's the one
early marvel movie you can't really
watch the credits for because it's just
like a rap sheet of criminals
yes yeah that's true it's awful
hey not not prosecuted yet but hopefully
soon will be
all right we've got more theories coming
up but first let's hear from our new
best friends
sometimes our online research for new
rockstars videos takes us into some
questionable directions i've been doing
a lot of searches with the term
kill count and that's not great for my
browser history
uh it's not really great for your mental
health as well i dream
of kill counts i i eat sleep and
bathe and kill counts uh it's times like
these that it doesn't matter what mode
you use or how many times you clear your
browsing history your internet service
provider can still see every site you
visited you know who else can
jesus christ and he's watching you at
least that's what my mom said
when she found some pictures of jennifer
love hewitt on my computer when i was
14.
she said what do you think jesus would
say why did you use the colored printer
to print out a full picture of her in a
bikini that didn't feel all right
that used all our coloring that was
really what was wrong about it okay
that's why whether at home
or at work we use expressvpn expressvpn
is an app that reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your isp can't see the sites you
visit ooh
it's like your special agent expressvpn
keeps all your information secured by
encrypting
100 of your data with the most powerful
encryption
available 100 is a good number if you're
looking to keep everything secret by the
way
some other people will give you 60 but
these guys they'll go 100 for you
and it runs seamlessly in the background
just tap one little button
and you're protected and it's available
on all your devices phones computers
and smart tvs pagers abacuses
etch-a-sketches you can block it all
i know a guy that can draw perfect boobs
on an extra sketch he's gotta block that
now
okay we're not safe protect your online
activity today
with the vpn rated number one by cnet
and wired
visit my exclusive link expressvpn.com
slash rogue and you can get an extra
three months free on a one-year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn
dot com slash rogue expressvpn.com
slash rogue to learn more eric tell us
more about some other fine sponsors
oh um we also want to thank our friends
at uh lumen skin so there are a lot of
reasons we
neglect our skin right we're busy we're
lazy
maybe we don't know what to do besides
splash water on her face know for the
best
or just if you're me crying cry and hope
that washes away the pizza grease
well the truth is that our skinheads
needs people it has needs
like a like a like a lover it has needs
like a like a the classroom pet that you
take home over the weekend it has needs
and if you don't
take care of it it will uh eat its own
feces and die
and your teacher will never let you put
it down well
if you want to look good as long as
possible you need to address those needs
there is a company that has taken all
the guesswork out of it for you
lumen so lumen is on a mission to give
men the amazing skin that
they they deserve you know they have
high quality expert creative products
delivered right to your door
all their products are formulated for
men's skin using top notch ingredients
like
charcoal green tea extract vitamin c
uh not just a giver of uh everyone's
favorite graduation song from the years
2000 through 2005
it's a it's a real thing that your skin
needs to keep you from becoming an
indiana jones villain
so lumen uh makes it easy to find the
right skin management system for you you
can choose different skin concerns to
address
like um uh whether it's dry or
uh translucent under uh certain lights
uh
and you just pick up a simple starter
pack for free uh
they were nice enough to give me this
this trial and it's been amazing i've
tried it the past couple nights this is
their moisturizing balm and it's like oh
i've never
used skin moisturizer before but it's
like i lay down in bed and i was like
what is that smell what does that smell
why is there a different man scent on my
pillow
and then i realized oh it's me it's me
and then uh i i sing and i wake up the
neighbors
and i feel like a man but i wake up with
slightly better feeling skin and you
deserve to look and feel your best
so here's what you do to start you just
go to lumenskin.com
rogue to get a one month free trial of
everything you need to start your skin
care journey at home that's
lumenskin.com
rogue to your first month for free
rogue another person we want to thank is
our friends at every plate
so folks i really like the convenience
of meal kit delivery services but you
know they can be
pricey every plate dinners are the
cheaper alternative to takeout or
delivery
their meals are the cost of a single cup
of coffee
and they taste great uh they
i got a shipment where it was smothered
pork chops chicken linguini and
shepherd's pie
i've never made shepherd's pie before i
just thought it was something you go
to you know if you go to a british pub
and you're like oh that sounds good
and it's unseasoned and flavorless like
all um british food is
this shepherd's pie i was like oh this
is what chef this is why people like
shepherd's pie because this is like the
best shepherd's pie
i've ever eaten and i made it that's it
it's me
um so it was a wonderful experience and
you can have it too
you'll have full plates and a full
wallet with america's best value meal
kit
get meals you'll enjoy and your bank
account will love
delivered right to your door with
contactless delivery
every plate does the meal planning the
shopping the prepping for you
every plate now offsets 100 of their
carbon emissions and they are constantly
expanding their shipment zones
as tommy said some people are only going
to be 60 100 percent
that's they're they're going all the way
they're going the full nine yards check
to make sure your zip code is eligible
at checkout and get three weeks of every
plate meals for only
299 2.99 per meal
by going to everyplate.com and entering
our promo code
three rogue that's the number three and
then r-o-g-u-e
for three weeks of meals for 299
per meal at everybody.com it's a crazy
good deal
definitely worth every cent all three
i've done other meal services before
two out of three are usually good if
you're lucky this one all three
slam dunks they were great so what
you're telling me is there's a scenario
where a glowing skinned eric voss serves
me a plate of steak and peas
all for the price of a cup of coffee and
i can
vlog about it on my computer which is
untraceable
because without even jesus seeing it oh
my god this is wonderful
you'd be a fool not to sign up for all
three i call it the tommy trio
it's like olive garden you sign up for
all three it's cheaper moving on moving
along onward and upward
every week we play a game a dangerous
game of rogue theory with our patrons on
the new rockstars discord
this week we had some patrons pitch
theories about what existing mcu
character
is going to become a villain in the
future with some really fun theories
this week from aj and afk
666. yeah afk 666.
the devil can see your searches as well
the devil loves when you search for bad
stuff
but our winner was voodoo bijou
with their theory about darcy lewis eric
enlighten us about this oh yeah so this
one's great and i love that we could get
you guys get on this because last week's
episode of rogue theories you know we
were kind of
doing some takes on which character he's
not a villain we'll be a villain
darcy i totally didn't see coming but
makes a ton of sense because not only
is she probably going to be part of
future thor movies she's going to be in
one division
she's going to play some role in that so
uh
basically uh voodoo bijou's theory was
that
loki embedded like asgardian powers in
darcy in some past conflict
and that uh darcy's gonna become the
mcu's amura the
enchantress which i think
would be totally great for cat denny's
to do
and in their theory they're saying how
jane foster is gonna have to fight
darcy slash enchantress in uh thor love
and thunder
which wow maybe it won't be the key plot
but i would love to see like as a
subplot
yeah i like that very good
you too can play along with us and have
your theory read
on an episode of rogue theory by
becoming a patron of the new rock stars
and joining our discord
all right topic number two there have
been
hundreds of deleted scenes across the 23
films of the mcu
that didn't make the final cut of those
films some of them were cut for time or
because they didn't add much to the
story
but others have been deleted scenes that
drop bombshells and make important
changes
to the mcu and to the mcu timeline as we
know it
pitch me on which of the mcu deleted
scenes should we consider as
canon okay let me jump in here tommy
um one that i like and it's a relatively
recent one
okay because i think it it it addresses
something that some people
don't like about um avengers end game
and that's during the battle of wakanda
in infinity war
right um that's when hulk or bruce
banner was in the like hulkbuster
um you know outfit he never turned into
hulk
so like there's a deleted scene in which
that is the moment that
uh bruce banner merges with the hulk to
form
right like there's a great clip of like
ruffalo's face
as he's like arguing with himself and
like bruce banner forum versus like hulk
form
and like it ended with um
him coming out as smart hulk and there's
like the big reveal is like
um uh black widow goes to like hey there
big guy
or whatever does the whole like magic
magic hand palm thing
and he's like what's up nat or whatever
and like blows her mind
i like that because like instead we got
all of the like merging of hulk and
bruce
happened off screen in between infinity
war and end game
and i don't know it would have been fun
to see that kind of happen in front of
our eyes right in this video
we would have got to see you know a full
hulk
uh fight thanos infinity war or be a
participant in the battle wakanda i like
that a lot
very nice very nice uh i
i'm a hulk guy you know i i the hulk is
near and dear to my heart
i'm gonna give you uh three hulk smashes
for that
three hulk smashes to go with your bows
and arrows
thank you those three strangely all uh
translated into this
uh lego rogue oh wow they said they they
she's small but this weighs 49 pounds oh
wow
yeah i like that all right you're so
strong
he's such a muscle boy it's so powerful
all right jessica what do you got for me
what do i got i got something yeah uh
hey yo teach
i got something so
let me turn my chair around and sit on
it so
let me lay it down for you so one of the
deleted scenes i really liked was
um in ant-man and wasp while
uh they were leaving the quantum realm
janet looked at her husband and said
that there was a lot of civilization and
a lot of people still
in the quantum realm so they deleted
that scene and why i would love that
scene to stay is because that can open
up the door to so many
extra mcu movies especially while we're
like i know i already
brought up like warlock but we're going
into the realm of now celestial
of like mcu world i know eternals was
already coming no matter what but it's
like if we get
into um the quantum realm we can talk
more about
magic because they also said that magic
could get you into the quantum realm
not only science so we could get into
those celentials we could get into the
eternals we could get into the deviants
we could get into all of those extra
characters that we haven't really talked
about
going through the quantum realm even
though like avengers end game did use
the quantum member a little bit we just
didn't see the people that were
in there yeah yes yes
i want that scene i would love that zayn
to be in there because they could have
done
they could have made like three
different movies yeah
yes yeah yeah yeah well as as anyone who
watches this show knows i'm very
passionate about that small city
in the quantum realm which i have not
named
someone called it uh what what did uh
what did hector call it on rogue theory
last week like microtown or something
like that
or micropolis or something micropolis
i'm calling it tinyville i'm calling it
tommy town
tiny tommy town triple t uh
anyway i'm gonna i'm i'm gonna shrink
down
shrink down two little ants and give you
two ants for that theory
two ants ooh those ants turned into this
sticky note
with my notes on it because you know i'm
a good student
and um wow this really expensive hydro
flask
wow well coming in you must know how
much
yeah you must be very important to have
that
uh and last but not least
go ahead eric tell us whatever you want
i guess uh i'm just kidding
i don't know if there's much more to say
i want to see where that piss went
i want to see who got peed on you
stepped in and said
who is peeing inside who gets blamed for
it
is there some poor asgardian pet who has
becomes an outdoor pet now
yeah thor couldn't find his bathroom
and just peed and rock it was like what
are you doing
what is going on so that's it that's
what i want
i want the word i want thor's golden
shower
uh i'm sure that's not the first time
that's been said i want
thor's golden shower uh just the first
time on camera
eric i'm gonna give you one uh two
two mule neuronals which are urinal
shaped like mjolnir
oh and uh those two become
what is the toilet of board games ticket
to ride
which people love taking a ride i
appreciate ticket to ride
i just have never won it i've played it
probably a dozen times and my mind
it's just the cards are too small they
give you these little baby cars that
make you feel like a big fat giant
and i like game pieces that are like
durable and
heavy and have weight to them but when i
play this game i feel like a big strong
muscle man zach cuddleston
and i want to feel like i have some
resistance working against me and ticket
to ride is not my
ticket all right very good well sponsor
the show ticket to ride
eric's changed real fast oh yeah dude
ride the best game of all time
i guess now is a tough time to say my
grandfather created ticket to ride and
he's dying
for you to play his game yeah maybe
because he invented such a terrible game
that he's not broken he's dying of a
broken heart
uh anyway that's great uh let's do a
quick recap of the scores
zach i believe you have uh six oh
feel pretty confirmed maybe i'm gonna
give me two and three
five okay you have five erica jessica i
believe you are tied at four each is
that correct that's
six you have six six i think you don't i
think i have
i think i have 12. wait a minute no i
have a i have 13.
so what i'm seeing here is uh you each
have between one and a hundred
uh so let's go let's settle this the way
i always like to
with a good old-fashioned round of rogue
questions all right
throw these at your lightning fast uh
and
just just give me whatever comes to your
mind don't overthink it guys ron howard
did an interview this week
where he called solo a star wars story
an underground hit
an underground hit just this cute little
indy that he made
uh during his vacation and uh just
tinkered around with
what's another really nice way of
describing a movie that bombed
why don't we use another movie that
bombed uh a dark phoenix still in the
nest
oh you never know it might rise again
yes
i like that in the nest i hate when
people use that
freaking literally calling it a cult
classic
yeah it was only popular like some for a
reason
yes yes yeah and mine's going to be
this is awesome this is also a term
sometimes used to describe people
that suck and that's a misunderstood
genius
[ __ ] yeah
yep yeah
your nephew is uh is quentin tarantino
yes nephew roast nephew roast all right
uh eric i'm giving you the point for
that one
although i do like some shade thrown at
nephews uh veteran character actor
wilford brimley
died this week he was only 84 but god
did he look 190
uh he was most recently famous for his
unique pronunciation of
diabetes diabetes diabetes
he said it died he was like it fell out
of his mouth
imagine if he said it correctly his
mustache filtered it
that's right uh what word do you
pronounce wrong
all the time well i'll i'll jump out and
say that
this is my achilles heel i mispronounced
them all the time
especially people's names i feel really
bad about that but as soon as it gets to
my head like
are you elena or alina that i'm done
i'll never get it right i'll always say
the wrong one you know yeah
but uh maybe for especially for this
show i'm always saying the wrong
is it symbiote or sim symbiote
well if you're uh if your what's her
name from from venice plate
it's if you're jenny slated sim by note
if you're any kid
that read comic books would be when i
was teenager it's symbiote
but i don't know it's symbiote or
symbiote i've heard
but the b has to be b not bi ah
well i i say it wrong no matter how i
say it yeah
um i have two words i say wrong
constantly as well
and it's jif jeff
yeah you're on the gym whatever the
and i hate when people use the peanut
butter as an excuse because i'm like i
don't eat the peanut butter
i say wrong all the time and then i say
not not the one in nemo but when you hit
someone in the blood
you have a
i can't pronounce it right at all and
luckily i don't have to say it a lot
oh yeah there you go that's good
sometimes i pronounce
uh gamora as nebula and vice versa
but i would say uh for me really it's
jaguar which i pronounced as jaguar
and i've said it a couple times in
videos man people hammer me for comments
but i don't know what it is
growing up in jacksonville in which our
nfl team is the jacksonville
jaguars i went to so many games
or to so many watch parties where
everyone in the room was saying the
jaguar
so i don't that's how i'll always say it
and it'll just spill out as jaguar
but i know it's jaguar or if you're in
english jaguar
you know it's jesus that's just british
people yeah british people they're
fanciness
frankly i think residents of
jacksonville should get dibs on that
like you guys should get to decide how
that word's pronounced
yes i went to jefferson middle school
and ours mascot was the jaguar and it
was
jaguar well i don't know what it is
you know what my theory is that people
in jacksonville are just like too polite
to correct you when you're wrong
so i just did oh jacksonville
yeah fair enough fair enough
uh all right i i'm gonna give you all a
point for that because
you all pronounce words more better than
i pronounce the wordies
uh all right next
the state of rhode island that's the
joke right there isn't it just kidding
if you're from rhode island the state of
rhode island
accidentally sent out tax refund checks
signed by
mickey mouse if mickey mouse was cutting
you a check what would it be for
oh if you're a fan of dc um mickey mouse
cuts all of new rockstars checks
but um yes hey hey hey
dc fandom's coming up we'll be covering
it um
i would say uh if mickey mouse were
cutting me a check
um it would be for um
pretending like captain marvel wasn't
skippable for a couple months
um yeah and if you like bob's burgers
which is a disney affiliate now
like how i work there please don't say
anything that i
disney don't come for me but um i love
you guys and you sign my checks
um i would say that disney uh pays me
to keep me silent from releasing
information about the ghost children in
small world
oh yes yes
oh i i i'm taking this in a very
different direction
so i went to grew up grew up in florida
like eric and
went to um disney world when i was very
young probably like age
four and i peed my pants
my parents threw out those pants and um
then i had to wear a
pair of pink um sweatpants from my
sister uh for the rest of the day
there's a lot of pictures of me with
like chip and dale and i'm in like
tiny girls thanks my fan so
mickey's cutting me a check for the the
pissed pants that my parents left in the
park
and of course as he does every year he
would cut me a check
for that cute little video me him and
minnie made for their anniversary a few
years ago oh my god
what no it's a music video
oh sure was it britney spears toxic
it was because you know you're toxic
that's right all right
uh you know i think we could go buy
points here or i could just pick a
winner
uh because you guys won't be honest with
you
uh i think at the end of the day the
person who really dazzled me from start
to finish here was
off-screen producer zach congratulations
congratulations i'm giving you the
winner what is your wish what what what
would you like to see us do before we
send you off
um oh that that's uh that's a good one i
didn't i didn't have a wish in mind and
thank you and i would like to think i'm
only getting this because i
i was the most vulnerable in my pissed
pants that's right there at the end when
i was in kindergarten
i not only pissed my pants i then stood
up and hit my head on the coat rack and
had to go to the nurse
for two reasons because i had they
thought i had a concussion
and and a pissed pants so that's a real
too for here
about me what okay boss when did you pee
your pants
um when i was yeah last week when i was
laying in bed
and i i said it's me
i released my body relaxed too much
helix mattress
my only wish was to hear at least one
more pissed pants
you've got two so far
everybody in the comments leave your pee
stories when you pick you guys
don't forget to smash that like button
and then write us an essay about when
you pissed yourself guys
come on that's the only way we're gonna
get through
[Laughter]
oh my god the only way quarantined will
end is if you reveal your piss stories
to us
that's it for this episode of rogue
theory i want to thank our guests pretty
ricky eric boss
pretty ricky jessica clemons and zach
huddleston you can find them all on
social media
god who cares what their handles are i
do
so we're going to put them underneath
their names that was a trick
and you all fell for it all right don't
forget to subscribe subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast feed and stay tuned
to the youtube channel for this
and other fun shows follow us on twitter
at new rockstars follow me on twitter
at this twitter handle i hope i'm not
just pointing to my crotch for no reason
john don't [ __ ] me on this
that's it for our show thank you to all
of our guests thank you to our winner
and honestly i date all three of you if
i could but uh
you're all much happier than i am and in
better relationships everyone have a
good night
[Music]
you